não o mundo nem sempre azul mas muitas
vezes depende de como vemos lembra
quando em dias de chuvas torrenciais
rezamos para que o céu se abra e de
repente um arco íris é pintado no céu e
nos encantamos é um milagre de deus
não nem sempre são flores o que vemos em
nosso jardim boa esperança onde só a
terra árida do desamor esse dia especial
do autista
o mundo não paga continua seguindo o seu
caminho perigoso mas nós vamos buscar a
pérola naquela concha tão fechada que é
o autismo
vamos o dia dos nossos sonhos pra vencer
o pesadelo do descaso
vamos calçar os nossos passos já tão
castos de andar
buscando vocês em algum lugar escuro
temos medo não podemos desistir muitas
vezes vergamos mas não podemos quebrar o
coração trincado de dor
o dia passa a vida segue
mas a luta jamais é em vão dia após dia
conscientizará humanidade que vocês não
são sombras são pessoas
guardadas do mal pelo autismo